ALEX LEVICH: Welcome to Women
Techmakers, Product Management
with Alex Levich.
I created the show
to show all of you
how a product manager plays
a key role in building
and launching products.
As you will see,
it's very exciting,
and I'm thrilled to introduce
Gayathri Rajan, Product Manager
and Director at Google.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: Thank you,
Alex, for inviting me.
ALEX LEVICH: It's our
pleasure, Gayathri.
Tell us about you
and your career.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: So I've been
a product manager at Google
now for more than nine years.
And over the course
of these nine years,
I've worked in a spectrum of
products ranging from payments
through to local commerce, and
now I work on Android with you,
building the next
generation of computers
and other interesting
new devices.
So it's been an
awesome experience.
I just feel like I've learned
so much about very, very
different product areas.
ALEX LEVICH: It is definitely
a range of products.
Tell us about how you
began your career.
I know that you actually did
start out as a product manager.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: You know
at 18, it's really hard
to know exactly what you want.
So I picked chemical
engineering,
because with
chemical engineering,
I got to stay an extra
year at Cambridge.
And I thought that was a pretty
cool thing to do at that time.
So I enjoyed-- I
enjoyed studying.
And then I went out and
worked as an chemical engineer
for a few years, but realized
that it was-- while I really
loved the engineering
aspects, I started
to feel that I was--
that was not exactly
the right career for me.
And at the same time, I was the
mother of two young children,
and various things
came together,
and I decided I was going
to go back to school
and do a master's in computer
science, because I really
loved-- even as a
chemical engineer,
I really loved to build
computer simulations,
to design destination columns,
and compressors, and all
those heavy equipment that you
see in chemical engineering
companies, they're actually
designed with computers
and using programming languages.
So I decided that was the thing
that I was going to do next,
and that's how I got
into computer science.
I was an engineer
first, learned really
how to build products as an
engineer, got very comfortable
with the programming
languages and all
the different technologies,
client server,
web mobile, et cetera.
And over the course
of that time realized
I really enjoyed
defining the products,
figuring out what the
right priorities were,
evangelizing the product
across large engineering teams,
more so than actually
building the product
to developing the code itself.
So that's how I moved
again from being a computer
scientist to a product manager.
So it's been--
ALEX LEVICH:It's
been quite a path.
GAYATHRI RAJAN:It's
been quite a path,
but I've learned
something along the way.
And when I became
a product manager,
I realized at that point I
was done, no more wondering.
This was the place I wanted to
be and really grow my career.
ALEX LEVICH: Tell me about
other product managers
that you've seen successful.
What other paths that people
that up to get us get here?
GAYATHRI RAJAN: At
Google, many people
take a fairly technical
path to get here.
So they've either
done computer science
or electrical engineering
or some kind of engineering
or science degree.
But, I've also seen very
successful product managers
who are now senior leaders
in the company, who
had a liberal arts background
and were still able to do
a very nice job building
credibility, and working
with engineers, and really
establishing themselves
as key product managers.
So really it just depends.
I think your background to
some extent helps lay out,
helps lay out your future.
It helps sort of at least
provide the right signals,
and it may give you
some of the skills
you need to get into product
management more easily,
but ultimately, the key
skill for successful product
managers, in my
opinion is as you said,
the love of building products,
building products that
can have impact, two people,
two people such as ourselves
and doing it with
a lot of people
and being really
excited and energized
about that whole process.
So really regardless
of your background,
if you have that core
passion of building product,
you can get there.
ALEX LEVICH: Yeah, it
makes complete sense.
That's probably what makes
us wake up every morning
and be excited about work.
It's that [INAUDIBLE]
for people.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: It's a great
career, product management,
because it doesn't
limit you in any way.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GAYATHRI RAJAN: Yes.
You learn you can move from
one product area to another.
You always take some skills
with you, the basic skills
of how do you
build products, how
do you set roadmaps, how do
you prioritize, how do you
define features?
These are very basic
fundamental skills
and talent that you can transfer
from one area to another.
But everything
else is completely
new within that space, and
that's where the excitement is.
That's where the excitement
is, because that's
when you learn about that
space, and what is needed,
and how you can then take
your basic fundamental skills,
but actually translate that
into a very different area.
So you can never stop learning
in product management.
It's almost inevitable
that you will never
be completely sure
of your domain
area, which also makes it very,
very much a growth experience.
So you can wake up in
the morning and you can--
I never feel like I kind
of know how to do this.
I can now do this in my sleep.
No, I have to wake
up and get in to work
and get fired up, because it
is-- everyday is a challenge,
but in a good way, because
everyday's a growth experience.
ALEX LEVICH: That's probably
one of the best things
one could wish about of their
job is wake up in the morning,
be excited, and be challenged.
GAYATHRI RAJAN:
Look at you, Alex.
Six months ago you were
working on a social platform
for Google, and now you are
building the next generation
of computers.
ALEX LEVICH: Yes, indeed.
Two very different things.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: Very different.
ALEX LEVICH: But the excitement
is the same, actually.
It is just like you say.
It's figuring out the
solutions every day
like it was the first day.
Gayathri, thank you so much
for joining us and sharing
your path.
Thanks, everyone, for tuning in.
This was Woman Techmakers
Product Management
with Alex Levich.
Stay tuned for upcoming episodes
to Woman Techmakers YouTube
channel.